you want fulfillment it comes through
other human beings it's not in a trophy
it will never be about your bank account
being a doctor was like just such a
revere now nothing's revered the people
who work at a hospital yeah they got
[ __ ] on you have a uniform on and uh
[ __ ] we don't serve you how can we bring
folks together like how can we say hey
man i understand your anger i understand
your rage nobody is comfortable in the
complicated mess
and the complicated message where it
happens that's where you have to live
the last thing i want to do is be
another [ __ ] celebrity spouting off
that being said bringing in people who
walk the walk instead of talk that [ __ ]
and like saying hey look this is like a
strong fierce educated kind empathetic
person like we can be that way and we
can like talk to people who think
differently than us you know might just
change a little bit of discourse
[Music]
he thinks i just [ __ ] put on makeup
and [ __ ] say live
[Music]
you